low low information voters who how do
you how do you
how do you deal with that i mean you've
got people who've been paying attention
who are saying right now i'm sick and
tired of being abused and insulted and
berated
but i look at some of my friends who are
out in california and they're just like
uh
i'm going to vote for modern and i'm
like why and like because trump's
destroying democracy and i'm like
how and they're like dude are you
serious and i'm like
i am dude oh we got it we got polls
closed in
14 seconds by the millisecond oh here we
go
69 seconds the amount of information i
have to give to someone to explain to
them
it's too much so so what happens is you
got a bunch of people sitting there and
then along comes lady gaga
and she's like i'm gonna vote for joe
biden
smash and she convinced 10 million
people i'm kidding
nobody was convinced by that but uh you
do get a lot of celebrities you get like
taylor swift
and she comes out and says vote biden
and a bunch of low information voters
are gonna be like yeah
and they're going to go vote indeed but
but low information voters
it sounds like an insult but most people
are rationally
it's not an insult right they're
rationally uninformed it makes sense to
not be informed
but the the like you even if you're
quote uninformed you still hear
white guys are the devil men are the
devil
though patriarchy is the devil and after
a while you just get tired of being
called the bad guy and you're gonna do
something about it
yeah but our i mean
is the white working class are the
projections good for trump in terms of
white working-class votes
you know i don't have the breakdown in
front of me tim my monitor my monitor
went down
uh but you know i don't know i mean it's
interesting to see how the latino vote
turned out for trump in florida we
talked about that here
uh after the one of the debates uh when
the telemundo
poll afterwards said that trump
decisively won it was a twitter poll
twitter poll but it is spanish speakers
who are following telemundo not english
speakers so indeed and you know we
talked about there how like
latino culture is based in machismo it's
based on strong male leadership
they're christians they're catholics
they're not into a lot of modernity as
it were
and so it was always seemed like stupid
to me to have latino voters
just lumped in with pocs and immigrants
and
you know african-americans who've been
here since the you know 16 16 19
not at all the same you know it's not at
all the same and so they're they'll like
uh you know critical race
you know race mongers on twitter are
already saying like oh
cubans aren't actual real latinos and
now latino voters are
the erasure this is the great erasure of
the latino vote
they're they're saying cubans aren't
latinos now no they're not a lot of
these people are like
not amazing to me that's shocking to me
and that disgusts me because those are
the people
who survive socialism those are the
people who survived who came across lost
crops
well remember it looks like trump is
winning ohio joe biden
you remember that joe biden said that
you know the uh
the latino community is a very diverse
community with
with uh very diverse thoughts and
yeah i mean but you know the african
unlike unlike the other community
they're a monolith right yeah
you ain't black which is which is just
you know
they were saying oh it didn't mean like
culturally
he meant politically it's like that's
still bad right it's still
it's still not a good thing to say i
mean everybody you can't lump everybody
into one community
uh you know or it's it's just i do not
understand
look how anybody can how anybody can
hear all these things
about joe biden and say well you know
trump's the racist
yeah i don't understand how how people
come to that conclusion
tv low information voters so look when i
say low information voters i'm not
saying stupid voters
i'm saying right they just don't have
all the people it's not
their job to read the news all day every
day so
i was i was actually insulting my friend
he's like i got no idea what i'm doing
but there are a lot of people who are
like wow it sounds like what they're
saying on the news is really bad
i better go vote and then in order so
i'll put it this way
i believe it is a lot easier to get a
low information voter motivated to vote
how you want
than it is to convince them with all of
your knowledge and information to vote
correctly well there's another
there's another term i shouldn't say
correctly in their interests
there's a there's another term for low
information voter and that's sheep
you know and and that's that's the
problem when you when you watch cnn
and you go uh wow they're they're saying
all these things and
i'm not orange men bad i'm not gonna
look it up i'm not gonna i mean i'm just
gonna take their word for it because you
know it's their cnn well
when you don't actually watch trump's
speeches and you only listen to what cnn
is saying about him
because i notice that when people pay
attention to what trump is actually
saying when they go and listen to his
speeches they're like
wow well that's a good that's an
interesting point right
because there was uh when when trump had
that
rally in tulsa a few months ago back in
june
i guess margin cnn
didn't show the speech what they showed
was a wide shot of the speech
and they were commenting on what he was
saying so when trump said something like
you know i tell them you know the more
cases the more testing we have the more
cases we have so
slow the testing down please and that's
and that was a joke
right it was a stupid joke it's
something he shouldn't have said
but then cnn goes you hear that he
said it he said to slow the testing down
can you believe it's like he said the
quiet part out loud it's like
if you watched him say it compared to
you know what cnn is saying and how
they're spinning it and
that's the thing that they don't they
don't show what he says they just say
what he wants to say the disinfecting
thing i thought was interesting
because it it's almost like a bell curve
of a stupid question where on the really
high end you probably roll your eyes and
say trump no
but then unlike at a certain point
you're like it's good that you're asking
these questions because we ask weird
questions sometimes to try and come up
with solutions
and then it was really funny that a
bunch of trump supporters started
showing uv light disinfectants that you
actually do put
down your lungs they exist and that
there are
there are uh chemical treatments that
you could inject but
what trump was talking about and the way
he asked it was just like
they were like you can use surface
cleaners to disinfect things and trump's
like i wonder if you can you know
disinfect by injecting or
you know inhaling and it's like yeah
it's like that's called medicine
right right right right and
interestingly though all these trump
supporters immediately
found this like new technology which is
a uv
light wand they they lower down the
throat into the lungs because it
actually does disinfect and kill like
bacteria and stuff
kind of cool like trump accidentally
like was kind of
onto something and before i go i want to
say that
you know at the debate when joe biden
and joe biden keep saying this he's like
well
trump said he said it you heard him say
it he said
to him did he told people to inject
bleach to kill the virus is like
he didn't say that right so with the
debates yeah uh
biden goes uh he said it he said over
there he said you've interrupted me and
he's like
it was a joke it's like no it wasn't a
joke you didn't say it right yeah you
didn't say
like trump i don't know i know right
it's so hard it's so hard to defend him
sometimes
it really is you don't have to defend
him no i want to defend him because
look all these fact checks from from the
uh
from the last debate it had trump going
you know this trump said this thing this
is false
definitively false but with biden it's
like needs context how come no one
or uh miss slightly misleading you know
what really has me ticked off
there's one fact check they never did
and they never fact check when joe biden
on a stage at a rally said shooting on a
shabbat pressure
no fact check what are we supposed to do
with that but i mean to be fair like
the media didn't say anything trump says
kefifi
they put on wikipedia right they named
horses after it they're all like a fifi
what an idiot
it was clearly a typo on twitter dude
well my my
thing is that you know joe biden
has been in he was in the senate for 36
years
he was vice president for eight years
and now
now he's gonna now he's not all right
now finally he's he's gonna i'm just
gonna bring everybody
for sure i know right now imagining i'm
imagining it's like
joe biden looks at his watch he looks at
a calendar and he and he marks a day and
it says 47 years
and he goes today's finally the day
and then he circles the day and it's
like do things for people
and that was it now he's like i'm gonna
i'm gonna do stuff for people
i saw i saw you look at your digital
watch and that reminds me when biden
looked at his digital watch and i'm
thinking were there notes on his
little apple watch like i wonder if
somebody was somebody
like nobody questioned this was somebody
like sending him like little texts like
oh yeah his name's not george it's it's
trump
you know just just uh you know just a
heads up just remember
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you